[Música]
en américa latina continúan los
esfuerzos de los gobiernos por vacunar
masivamente a su población méxico
autorizó el uso de emergencia de la
vacuna rusa sputnik mientras que en
chile o inicia el plan de vacunación
contra el cob y 19 y 6 puede inmunizar
alrededor de 5 millones de personas en
el primer trimestre de 2021
en eeuu al presidente joe biden firmó
una segunda serie de órdenes ejecutivas
para revertir las políticas migratorias
de su predecesor los decretos en cuanto
a la separación de familia seguridad
fronteriza e inmigración legal elevan a
9 el número de acciones ejecutivas de
bailén en materia migratoria en sus
primeras dos semanas en la presidencia
el presidente de italia sergio mataré la
encargará al economista mario draghi la
formación de gobierno drag y comparece
hoy miércoles tras el fracaso de las
negociaciones entre los partidos de la
coalición el ex presidente del banco
central europeo recibirá al país sumido
en una profunda crisis económica
mientras batalla contra la pandemia
muy buen día bienvenidos a las noticias
entradas 24 su ron blanco como siempre
un gusto saludarlos comenzamos a en
américa latina y el avance de la
vacunación masiva contra el hobbit 19 en
algunos países de la región en las
últimas horas se conoció que el gobierno
del presidente mexicano andrés manuel
lópez obrador autorizó el uso de
emergencia de la vacuna rusa sputnik
según el mandatario durante una
conversación telefónica con su homólogo
vladimir putin se negociaron 24 millones
de dosis del antídoto méxico es el
tercer país con más muertes por la
pandemia con al menos 159 mil 500
decesos y más de 1.8 millones de casos
confirmados como prisa acaba de otorgar
la autorización de uso de emergencia a
la vacuna sputnik be creada por el
instituto el centro de malilla de
biología y microbiología de rusia y por
lo tanto existe ya la posibilidad
y que se importe y de que sea utilizar
pasamos ahora a chile donde hoy el
gobierno pondrá en marcha su plan de
vacunación masiva con la esperanza de
inmunizar alrededor de 5 millones de
personas en el primer trimestre de este
año el país sudamericano cuenta desde la
semana pasada con al menos 2 millones de
vacunas del laboratorio chino sinovac el
acuerdo de acuerdo al ministerio de
salud se dará prioridad el suministro de
la vacuna al personal de salud centro de
servicio nacional de menores residencias
sanitarias y también residentes de casas
para adultos mayores desde el pasado 24
de diciembre alrededor de 56 mil
personas en chile han recibido la vacuna
de facer by and age
y en su sexto día de misión los expertos
de la organización mundial de la salud
llegaron este miércoles al instituto de
virología de wuhan como parte de su
investigación sobre el origen del hobbit
19 en esta ciudad china el instituto
cuenta con varios laboratorios de alta
seguridad donde los investigadores
trabajan con coronavirus en su momento
el entonces presidente de estadounidense
donald trump acusó al instituto de dejar
salir el virus que causó el kobe 19
provocando esta pandemia mundial
una acusación de beijing ha negado
tajantemente
y el presidente de eeuu joe biden y
firmó una serie de órdenes ejecutivas
que buscan modificar algunas de las
políticas migratorias de la
administración anterior el mandatario
aspira a crear un sistema de asilo
compasivo lograr una inmigración segura
y ordenada así como reunificar las
familias de migrantes que fueron
separadas entre otros puntos
andrés meza muñoz nos da más detalles en
el informe
yo vaivén continúa revirtiendo las duras
políticas migratorias de su antecesor el
presidente firma una nueva serie de
órdenes ejecutivas destinadas a reparar
el daño de la administración trump entre
ellas una para reunir a los casi 1000
niños que fueron separados de sus padres
en la frontera sur bajo la política de
'tolerancia cero' a la migración ilegal
del ex líder republicano jon queremos
poner en marcha un proceso de
inmigración aquí que sea humano que sea
moral que considere solicitudes de
refugiados solicitudes para que las
personas entren a este país por la
frontera de una manera que trate a las
personas como seres humanos tweets tipo
de siemens y otra para revisar una serie
de políticas de la hera trump como el
procesamiento de solicitudes de asilo
además de una revisión general al
sistema migratorio para garantizar que
funcione correctamente
los críticos de baire manifestaron su
miedo a que la reforma migratoria
provocará un efecto llamada de migrantes
especialmente desde centroamérica pero
la administración del demócrata ha
advertido que los cambios tomarán tiempo
este no es el momento de venir a eeuu
necesitamos tiempo para implementar un
proceso de inmigración para que las
personas puedan ser tratadas con
humanidad misma
estas nuevas órdenes pasan a engrosar el
voluminoso paquete de medidas
migratorias implementadas por la
administración vader
entre las que se encuentran poner fin a
la construcción del muro fronterizo con
méxico y proteger a los llamados
dreamers jóvenes indocumentados que
llegaron ilegalmente a territorio
estadounidense cuando eran niños y es
que precisamente el presidente de eeuu
yobái dennison una visita nocturna al
capitolio para rendir homenaje a brians
y cnic el oficial de policía del
capitolio asesinado cuando partidarios
del ex presidente de donald trump
irrumpieron en el edificio el mes pasado
en una ceremonia solemne los líderes
demócratas y republicanos del congreso
se presentaron en la rotonda del
capitolio para estos homenajes en los
hechos de violencia del 6 de enero
asique nick los rociaron con gas
pimienta y lo golpearon en la cabeza
según informó su padre
un tribunal de parís encontró culpable
al estado francés por no cumplir con sus
compromisos para frenar las emisiones de
gases de efecto invernadero en un fallo
histórico celebrado por los activistas
como una victoria para el clima tras del
fallo
ordenaron pagar la suma de un euro en
compensación por el prejuicio moral
el veredicto tiene además un valor
simbólico ya que justamente en parís se
firmó hace cinco años un acuerdo
internacional que tiene como objetivo
limitar claramente el calentamiento
global al menos de dos grados
centígrados
en italia el expresidente del banco
central europeo mario draghi recibe hoy
el encargo de formar gobierno drag y se
reunirá con el presidente italiano
sergio matar el a quien asegura que
italia necesita un gobierno de alto
nivel esto mientras el país lucha contra
la pandemia y una profunda crisis
económica la decisión se registra es la
incapacidad de los antiguos socios del
gobierno para llegar a un acuerdo que
lleve a la formación de un nuevo
ejecutivo
un gobierno de alto nivel sin alianzas
políticas esa es la visión que el
presidente sergio mataré la tiene para
italia tras semanas de agitación
política y mientras el país se enfrenta
al coronavirus y a su peor crisis
económica en décadas
alberto por tanto el dow verde es mi
deber hacer un llamado a todas las
fuerzas del parlamento para que otorguen
su confianza a un gobierno de alto nivel
no vinculado a ninguna fuerza política
identificarse con alguna fórmula
política esta etapa requiere un gobierno
sólido en el saber su función
el hombre encargado de la misión sería
el ex jefe del banco central europeo
mario draghi que no es ajeno a la crisis
apodado supermario el economista
italiano tiene el mérito de haber
salvado a la eurozona en el punto más
álgido de la crisis de deuda en 2012 si
es elegido como primer ministro tendrá
mucho trabajo por hacer
italia fue uno de los primeros países
europeos en verse afectado por la
pandemia hasta ahora han muerto más de
89 mil personas la economía se contrajo
un 8.9 por ciento en 2020
la peor recesión desde la segunda guerra
mundial y el año pasado se perdieron más
de 420 mil puestos de trabajo incluidos
más de 100.000 solo en diciembre draghi
sería el encargado de elaborar el plan
de recuperación de italia que estuvo en
el centro de los enfrentamientos dentro
del gobierno saliente y que llevaron a
la dimisión del ex primer ministro josep
conté la semana pasada mataré la espera
que el nuevo gobierno sea respaldado por
el parlamento advirtiendo que la
celebración de elecciones anticipadas
dejaría a italia en un estado de caos
durante un momento crucial en otras
noticias la policía mianmar presentó
cargos contra la líder de roca dance and
such y por supuestamente violar una ley
de importación-exportación y solicitó su
detención hasta el 15 de febrero según
un documento policial también los
oficiales militares que registraron la
residencia de sochi encontraron un
aparato de rastreo telefónico cuyo uso
solo está permitido por el gobierno o el
ejército lo que le puede costar hasta
tres años de cárcel por su parte los
ministros de exteriores de los países
que integran el g7 expresaron su
preocupación por él
golpe de estado-militar del pasado lunes
en bien mar y apelaron al ejército a
restituir el poder al gobierno
los organizadores de los juegos
olímpicos de tokio revelaron la agenda
que detalla las medidas contra el hobbit
19 que se tomarán durante las justas de
verano de este año dijeron que los
atletas y funcionarios no deben usar el
transporte público sin permiso y les
pidieron que usen una mascarilla en todo
momento durante el evento excepto cuando
coman o duerman también pidieron a los
fanáticos que no cantaran ni gritaran
para apoyar a los atletas
y esta manera llegamos al final de la
informativa en france 24 continúen con
nosotras felicidad para todos
[Música]
el espacio de france 24 dedicado a
ofrecer